sin está padeciendo el rebrote más grave
desde que la pandemia surgiera en wuhan
hace dos años son cientos de casos
repartidos en 19 de las 31 provincias se
han obligado a confinar varias ciudades
enteras a pesar de que se hubieran
detectado sólo media docena de casos es
la política de 'tolerancia cero' que
sigue vigente en china a pesar de que el
75% de la población está vacunada y en
previsión de nuevos confinamientos el
ministerio del comercio ha recomendado a
las familias que hagan acopio de
alimentos básicos como verduras o fideos
instantáneos y objetos de emergencia
como linternas aquí en pekín en vísperas
de un importante cónclave del partido
comunista también se han extremado las
restricciones se han cancelado las bodas
se ha recomendado que los funerales se
celebren con el menor número posible de
personas y bares de distintos distritos
han recibido la orden de cerrar durante
las dos próximas semanas